how did it feel to win the award at last
I I know what my friend did get it to
Susan Lucci a Bennigan's third one are
you of the best wardrobe
gaastra like everything else absolutely
everything helps and I was lucky patent
lucky right my feet or better than other
people so we don't you get to sort of
people let them do their job and you use
concentrate on your job so everything
help the hair and make it the wig the
Wardrobe what were the calendars view
playing such an iconic character
gosh sometimes I can't believe I did I
because the challenge is where anyways
to have had to remove the fact that she
was an icon and and put that out of your
mind because it would be too daunting
and instead trying to think of her as a
girl as an ordinary girl which is good
what she wanted to be for another one
hour American everybody
us
I don't know if there was one quality
there wasn't a single there really
doesn't sort of i wanted to direct
packed in to her I found the only way it
was with time was so much time and
letting I don't know any way that
incurred dictate the way letting her
take shape letting all this dirt of
information take a shape and then
instead of trying to me control it
how did i start i was thinking with the
different answer so the war everybody
has no I I took my time I took my time I
did everything that anybody know if
anyone was a person as I rounded do it I
did you can even watch all the movies
read all the books you go on YouTube you
do your hood student here let you become
a really good student then you take time
and let yourself be really bad for a
while um and you pushed your backyard a
bombshell would you say it's more
difficult to created characters I've
only ever existed on the stretch or
adapt a realtor
oh I think he's a cute whatever you're
working on in the moment feels like the
hardest thing that you're working on
because it's confronting you on a daily
basis with your sort of shortcomings and
I can get better at and so I feel like
whatever you're wrestling with at the
moment always filled with the most
challenging dreamers and biscuits and
your when you go to trust your award was
average both days
prepare your own clothes snap between
Thailand
with it post your teasing a christian i
don't i don't know i'm sure that there
are some but it would take me seeking
more tighter they have to think of one
unfortunately queda quote that equitable
image i like putting a little put in
some words in your pocket and thinking
about them but i don't nothing is coming
too right now
oh I don't know I just I just doing some
work and I don't know I just do some
work I just I don't know I just had to
keep my head down which is a very sort
of actually Montana attitude in a way
you're sort of I don't know there's
amish thing or take your thing that i
like sort of heart to the ground are to
the ground and no eyes to the ground at
heart to the side so i don't know i just
kind of keep those what I up and fly
search on Carolyn
favorite quote from her